- Hey guys, I'm going all
over the office today,
and asking people if
they're registered to vote.
And if not, I'm gonna
show them how to do it.
Are you registered to vote?
- Yes, I am!
- I think I am, I've voted before.
- I am registered to vote.
- [Interviewer] Where?
- In California.
- [Interviewer] Oh, great!
Where are you gonna vote?
- Michigan.
- Here.
- In the state of California?
- Sure am!
- In Massachusetts.
- Everyone here is registered to vote.
This whole row is great,
good job citizens.
- Yeah, I'm registered and informed.
- I just transferred my registration from
the state of Florida to California!
- Yes. Did you do it online?
- I did because everything
should be done online,
'cause that's how you're going
to get young people to do it.
- How easy was it?
- The easiest thing I've ever done.
- I need to register to vote,
and because, you know what people tell me?
If I don't vote, I have
no excuse to complain.
- I was registered in
the state of Illinois
last election when I lived there.
- Do you wanna register to vote
in the state of California?
- Yeah!
- You can do that right
now, it takes 30 minutes.
- 30?
- Three.
- Oh, really?
- Yeah.
If you live in California,
registring to vote is super easy.
You can do it online!
All you need is a California issued ID,
last four digits of your
social security number,
and your date of birth.
And you should be done!
She's almost done with her registration.
This is a really big day.
Here's a website if you're
not from California.
She did it!
- It was painless.
- Just vote, ya dummies, it's so easy.
- It's so easy!
- So easy, why not!
- Listen, you gotta register to vote
because you can't just talk,
you gotta walk the walk.
- Like if you have different beliefs
than the state that you live in,
I still think it's important to vote.
- So, it turns out, a
lot of people at BuzzFeed
are registered to vote.
Which is super great and super awesome.
You should do that too!
All elections are important.
Local elections, primary
elections, midterm elections,
presidential elections,
vote for all of them.
- So go out and register
to vote, Kanye 2020.
- Well...